I think that the world that matters is
the world that we perceive not the world
that is out there so in many experiments
we show that our expectations about how
the world should function influences the
way we actually experience the world so
if you go ahead and you buy a cold
medication on discount you expect it to
be worse as a consequence your
physiology doesn't take it that doesn't
kick in as much and you are not helped
as much by this cold medication now you
can say which one is the reality that
the cold medication is the same
regardless of the price or the reality
that actually changes your physiology
and I think it's the one that changes
our physiology maybe the best examples
for this is to think about placebo so
placebo is real many people think of it
as just psychology but there's nothing
just about it it turns out the data
physician comes to you and injects you
with whatever saline water your body
expects pain relief and your body
secretes substances that are very much
like morphine so it doesn't matter what
you get from the injection you actually
get pain relief from your own body as a
reaction to that now you can't just
close your eyes and say please can I
have some painkillers this doesn't work
but when the physician injects you with
anything even saline water you get the
pain relief that is actually a substance
you can't buy over-the-counter it's like
morphine now
what is the reality there is the reality
is the physician injected you with water
saline water or is the reality that the
physician actually gave you pain relief
from my perspective the important
reality is the reality people experience
because that's what we come in contact
with that's what we know and that's the
reality we make decisions based on